[Music]
hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over the ready opening and the
reading ready opening starts out with
Knight to f3 this is a hyper modern
chess opening which if you're not too
familiar with that term just basically
means you're attacking the sinner with
your minor pieces which are your knight
and your bishop instead of using your
pawns at the beginning obviously
eventually we will get our pawns
involved but this move right off the bat
just develops our knight which allows us
to Castle kingside quicker and at the
same time attacks in defense the d4 and
the e5 square which are vital squares in
any chess game in the center now as you
can see from this opening and this right
here is actually just the opening just
that one simple move but it can
transpose into a lot of different
openings and so the main line for the
ready
basically all depends on which route you
want to go you can transpose into the
roy lopez you can transpose into the
Queen's Gambit the English so we'll go
ahead and get into those it's a move
that if you like to mix things up and
you don't like to get trapped into maybe
some of the
defined offenses that people have you
can kind of mix this into your game
because you can basically transpose into
any opening that you would like so just
one example Knight to f3 black a lot of
times we'll just come to pawn to d5
from here we can kind of transpose into
the English which is the C for obviously
black can't capture but then we can just
bring our our pawn here to the e3 square
kind of like the the Queen's Gambit our
Bishop will be here we can always bring
our Queens through the action if we need
an extra defender but from here black
can come let's say e6 probably not going
to take this although you may see it
from here we're gonna bring up to d4 and
you can see it's really starting to look
like the the queen's gamut from here
black develops to f6 and then from here
we have Knight to c3 and this right here
is the Queens gambit declined and we got
here solely from the ready opening so
you can already see another variation
you may see just as black mayor's on the
opposite side to c3 and then here we can
just simply bring our pawn to e4
attacking this light Square and we're
attacking the dark squares with our
with our night here and then if black
decides to bring is pawn to e5 then
right here you can already see that we
can go into a gioco piano starting at
the Bishop to c4 square or we can just
play the Royal Lopez the Bishop to b5
and then obviously we talked about we
can start out here and then if black
decides to come to d5 which is probably
the most common opening that you will
see and then white can respond just
simply pawn to e4 and then really
doesn't matter where where black goes
again if if he does take we can we can
just bring our pawn to e3 and attack
that piece and if we need to bring extra
attackers into it we can easily regain
that piece as you can you can probably
tell but from here black may develop and
we're just going to develop just like we
would in any English opening did another
video on the English opening if you want
to check that out but from here if you
were just to look at this you might not
even know which way white started if he
started with pawn to c4 and then brought
his Knight to c3 and then developed f3
you just can't really tell because with
a ready opening it can just transpose
into too many different openings one of
the big openings that you'll see
a lot of times with this is the Kings
Indian defense and the Kings Indian
defense is a very popular opening with
the ready opening and I'll be doing a
video on the Kings in the end or excuse
me the Kings Indian attack I'll be doing
a video on this a little bit later but
the Kings in the attack basically you're
going to fianchetto your Bishop and then
it's going to look it's going to look a
whole lot let me get this this image up
for you guys here it's going to look
like this image right here the bishop is
fianchettoed on the g2 Square attacking
this diagonal the night here on f3 is
where we developed at the beginning and
then we have brought our knight here to
the d2 square where he can easily access
more squares and from here we can we can
even fianchetto our bishop on the Queen
side obviously with our LightSquared
Bishop Finch headed on the g2 Square
we're going to castle on the King side
and this is a very good attack it has it
gives a wide a lot of different options
as you can see we have great sooner
control our control is right now focused
on the light squares due to the fact
that our our main pawn here on e4 is
attacking the light squares but this is
just another opening that the ready
opening can transpose too so hopefully
you gather from this that the ready
opening is a great opening if you like a
lot of
versatility in your openings if you like
to change things up and you like to play
your openings depended on what your
opponent does instead of having it a
find attack at the beginning and letting
black counter that the ready opening is
definitely something that you can
transpose into a lot of different
openings so study the ready as far as
different openings that you would like
to to play with it and if you know you
know the Kings Indian attack the the
Queen's Gambit and the English opening
pretty well then this actually could be
a very good opening for you as you can
you can basically dive into those three
openings very quickly as long as the as
well as the roy lopez which you'll see
off into so i hope you guys enjoy this
video please subscribe helped out a lot
leave comments forming questions there's
any other videos you guys want to see
and
please rate the videos appreciate it and
I'll see you guys next video